congratulations i see the ring is i see
it from a mile away
how did you know that he was the one and
how is wedding planning going can't wait
to see your new show
well carter and i have been friends for
15 years and
as soon as we actually had our first
kiss about a year and a half ago i just
had this spark with him and i knew he
was the one and i'm so excited to be his
wife and
i can't wait for the next phase of my
life with them what can you tease about
the show what will we see wedding
planning wise
everything so it's going to be finding
the wedding dress
the venue is this a big wedding i'm
trying to decide because of what's
happening in the world
yeah i would have had a very big wedding
but might need to be a little bit
smaller than i thought
why did you want to let everybody into
this process well i just signed a big
deal with warner brothers so i have
my own production company now called
slivington manor entertainment
and i just thought this would be the
perfect first project and
with my documentary i opened up in so
many ways but i want people to see that
i did find my happy ending and it's just
the next phase of my life and it's just
going to be
exciting to share that with my fans you
are one of the iconic og's of reality tv
since we're here at mtv movie and tv
awards unscripted what would you tell
people now about how to
kill it on reality tv i think it's all
about just having a good time
being yourself and having fun you only
live once
i have loved watching you own your past
lately um
loved the tick tock where you debunked
the stop being poor shirt so there's
this photo online of me
i'm sure you've seen it i never wore
that shirt
this was completely photoshopped
everyone thinks it's real
but that's not the truth i had to do it
they've been saying that for so many
years
i would never wear a shirt that said
that i think that's the most obnoxious
thing i've ever seen in my life
so for years i've just had people
thinking that so i was like you know
what i'm just going to tell the truth
it's time to tell the truth i mean you
have so many fans and we're also like
we're in this age of nostalgia i know
britney spears mentioned you the other
day you mentioned her on your social
media i love
seeing that how much do you guys still
stay in touch
i love her i was actually texting with
her last week and she's just
so sweet and down-to-earth and really an
amazing woman
and i'm just so proud of her we need to
get brittany back on the ready yes
what do you think has brittany found her
one and sam i think they're really cute
together i do too
he seems to really care which i like
yeah he makes her happy and smile
[Music]